groupthink is something that i battle
all the time i can't stand it
it exists
it's very strong on the left it also
exists on the right there are segments
of the right that like everyone to tell
a line and everyone to agree all the
time
it's much more prevalent from what i've
seen on the left and much more empowered
and much more um
well organized should i say and and much
more prevalent that's my experience
but i want to get to something that i
teased earlier which was a story about
an animal shelter
in california and this animal shelter
is banning nra supporters from adopting
pets
some of you may have seen this story
it's called the shelter hope pet shop
and it's in thousand oaks california
and essentially it says if you support
the nra if you're not a gun control
advocate
you cannot adopt this is this is a true
story this is not made up
um i know it sounds funny but it's not
and this is from the hill can we pull
that up tyler that column from the hill
that i don't know if you have that but
it says california animal shelter to
require those adopting pets
to support gun restrictions
um
so i'm just gonna i'm just gonna flip
through this a little bit to some of the
things that hope the shelter hope
headshot owner kim still feels very
strongly about this
and she wrote on the organization's
website if your beliefs are not in line
with ours we will not adopt a pet to you
so that's telling right there just stop
there for a second why
why why
does everyone need to agree with you to
adopt a pet why
does it stop at gun control i'm just
curious because gun control is a
political point it's it's very
contentious with a lot of debate a lot
of discussion
serious
guns are serious right we've seen some
shootings very serious trauma
very personal but does it stop there so
if i open a shelter and i say well i
don't
i don't want to adopt out to people who
support gay rights that cool is that
that would get a ton of backlash but is
that is it cool
again i'm going to go back to how i feel
about this she's in this is her animal
shelter
she can do whatever she wants
is it bad policy to me yes it's
profoundly bad policy and in this case
the only people the only i should say
well animals are people but to me the
only people that are getting hurt
are the cats dogs the pets
because now these pets can't go to the
homes of law-abiding
citizens who just happen to support
maybe their nra members maybe they feel
that it's important to have a gun to
protect and defend their families
they're not harmful
they're not going to hurt those pets
they're not going to injure those pets
so what's the reasoning there the
reasoning is that she needs you to agree
or be punished
the group thinkers need you to agree or
be punished you don't get a you don't
get a cat
you don't get a cat you don't get a
puppy you don't get a puppy are you
gonna change your mind if you change
your mind you'll get a puppy
oh no okay you don't get a puppy someone
else gets i mean this is like it's very
third grade but it's also happening you
don't agree we're gonna de-platform you
on social media
you don't agree well we're gonna try to
pull your funding for your film
it's happening all over this is one
example
um so the owner comes in and says also
by the way if you lie about being an nra
supporter make no mistake we will sue
you for fraud
go in the extra mile there
go in the extra mile to take dusty away
that's the cat never had a cat named
dusty
should have
honestly i had no because i had a cat
that did kind of look like a dust rag
now that i think of it i had several
cats chopsticks my mom named them all
scungilli
let's not get into that solange is
watching at home she's like don't share
the stories about our pets aj
i will mom one day i will anyway
so
this owner happens to feel very strongly
about this she said that um
you know watching the shooting in texas
the school shootings she said that
someone at one point she thought
had been arrested and involved
potentially in a shooting and may have
uh volunteered at the shelter what this
is personal regardless of the details
this is very personal for her she's
entitled
to that opinion
but it's bad policy it's bad policy and
it's terrible to say to people you agree
with me or you don't get a cat
what
so um if you go on the facebook page to
follow up for i went over to the shelter
hope pet shop facebook page i wanted to
see a little bit more of her explanation
and to see some of the comments i was
curious how this was being received this
is california remember
and she added
this is i'm guessing the owner because
it says author
to the many angry humans who posted
comments here i will say it again i
should not have to carry a gun to
protect myself my shelter and to protect
my staff animals and volunteers i have
the right to adopt to like-minded beings
in regard to gun control
okay
so this is interesting
yes you have a right to do that it's
painfully transparent that you're a
group thinker you have a right to do it
but sad sad for where you are i feel
deeply sad for the owner of this uh
shelter
as someone who has been spent my whole
life surrounded by people who agree and
disagree with me and i've never had to
run into a safe space or threaten them
here we are
um also an important point to bring up
that she mentions here she says i
shouldn't have to carry a gun to protect
my shelter okay well in a utopia or in
the wizard of oz you probably don't
that's great
but what happens i would love to ask her
if your shelter somebody decides that
they're
a criminal right they're a bad person
they decide well you know what i'm going
to hold up this shelter i'm going to
steal the pets i'm going to harm i'm
going to steal money i'm going to do
something horrible and they show up at
your front door what is your solution
do you understand now why it would be
incredibly beneficial for you to have
someone in that facility who has been
well trained
who has you know been checked out who is
of sane mind who who knows what they're
doing
and has a firearm
or is your plan to
hide call the police and hope for the
best
how close are you to the police station
how long does it take for them to get
the message hop in their car put their
siren on and drive on over
are they going to come running in or are
we going to see an issue with law
enforcement where they decide oh let's
mull it around in the hallway for a
little while before we go in
so what i'm trying to point out here is
i hope nothing terrible ever happened i
want this shelter i love animals
more than humans most days of the week
except for my child and my husband
everyone else second to animals sorry
mom and dad no i'm kidding but um really
i love animals everyone who knows me
knows i have a soft spot for animals
never want anything terrible to happen
you know would be horrific but i'm just
presenting that as like hey just
for a moment
just remove your politics from this and
remove the stuff the slogan of gun
control and remove the like
oh i want to you know fit into what's
going on just think for a second think
use common sense
these self-defense measures exist
because people want to protect
themselves they want to protect their
animal shelter they want to protect
their staff they want to protect their
families okay
there's a lot of people out there and a
lot of those people want to adopt pets
from a place like this and they're not
harmful and they're not seeking to do
harm but they are going to come in handy
plenty if there's a bad guy or gal out
there with a gun that seeks to do harm
you're gonna wish for that person to be
there i promise you i feel safest
safest safest when i'm in places where i
know
that law-abiding citizens are armed
no question
no question
so
i think what really bothered me about
that story was yes the group think angle
but also also just the unwillingness to
recognize that
you're putting yourself in a position
that's horrible for what you know maybe
you don't like guns maybe you didn't
grow up with guns i didn't grow up with
guns i grew up in new york city i grew
up in new york city where it was like
the police had guns and the bad guys had
guns
that was really how i grew up i didn't
grow up in a house where you were
trained to use a firearm my parents
didn't have firearms so it was very new
to me and it took a second of me kind of
warming up to the idea that oh you can
you know you can
you can these things can be used for
good and i had to kind of broaden my
mind coming from you know manhattan girl
and all that but
all it takes is just a little bit common
sense to just sit back and say i see
where these people are coming from even
if you don't get there all together
maybe you're still a gun control
advocate
but see where these people are coming
from
just a thought on any issue if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]